cette semaine dans le bloc-notes la
nouvelle recette de cauchemar en cuisine
sur m6 marie porto la nouvelle égérie du
meilleur pâtissier et toutes les
révélations sur les salaires des
candidats de la star ac bref vous l'avez
compris un bloc notes aux petits oignons
le mercredi le chef philippe etchebest
était de retour sur m6 accompagné de
l'ancien candidat de top chef malric ap
six ans le chef il m'a envoyé en mission
il peut compter sur moi et il n'en fait
pointereau d'être 2 quand on connaît
l'état des restaurants dans l'émission
et elle ne
causera une animation bio qui ne suffit
pas a fait recette car seulement 2,24
millions téléspectateurs étaient devant
leur écran
pour est en cuisine avec le meilleur
pâtissier quitter son grand retour jeudi
7 octobre avec une nouvelle animatrice
aux commandes très très heureuse de vous
retrouver après postic olaf et julia
vignali c'est au tour de marie portolano
l'ex journaliste sportif de canal + de
mettre la main à la pâte on est content
ce soir une dixième saison anniversaire
qui sera particulière avec de nombreux
invités et des épreuves en tout genre
enfin alors qu'un autre anniversaire
approche celui les 20 ans de la star
academy et d'anciens candidats
reviennent sur leur aventure et plus
particulièrement sur leur salaire dans
l'émission allez on note alors si bon de
la saison 2 a déclaré on était payé 3000
euros par semaine dans le château on
avait une petite prime je crois de 1000
euros pour les prime et après en tournée
c'était 450 euros par soir armande altaï
qui était quant à elle professeur de
chant a révélé au début mon salaire
était d'environ 5000 800 euros pour 13
semaines soit plus de 1800 euros par
mois ensuite face au succès phénoménal
de l'émission c'est monte aux alentours
de 5000 euros timbres des sommes
d'argent considérables qui témoigne du
succès faramineux du télé crochet à
l'époque c'est la ligue des champions ce
soir
allez il est temps pour nous de refermer
ce bloc notes et de vous dire à la
semaine prochaine
sinon c'est l'ouverture les familles
salaire de la star ac est ce que allah
dit la vérité alors elle a pas alors je
me suis envie d'appeler car même alexia
laroche-joubert louvain alors que la
décennie à la grande patronne à rio à
alexia mollahs et puis qu'il a dû
château n'est pas neuve en attend des
alpes et donc j'essayais damocles avec
la réserve si la famille pour une fois
vous est servi à quelque chose
alors oui en fait à elle s'est alors
elle s'est trompée sur alors 1000 euros
par prime nous on n'avait pas de sou sur
les prennent je comprends pas comment
ils aient pu avoir mis leurs pas et que
personne s'en rappellent qu'ils donnent
et 2000 euros à ceux qui savaient
chanter ce qui devrait cartonner temps
je plaisante ajoutait
nous on avait donc quoi le smic donc par
mois ci avec nous on avait 1200 euros
par mois donc c'était 7000 francs à
l'époque rihouet alors mais c'était la
vérité pourquoi en fait les intras tara
qui étaient calqués sur ceux de l'époque
du loft et que c'était en fait une
grille tarifaire été après été remises
en cause ce qui effectivement il ya des
avis du ciel il ya eu des procès qui ont
été menés on le fait comme tel il a même
fait vite au niveau pro c'est parce
qu'on est passé can 2002 cymbales par
mois à 3000 par semaine mais m et ça
j'ai pas eu le voilà on m'a pas dit que
tu es vraiment alors être au milieu ne
sais pas je mets pas en cause la norme
et on ne me l'a pas confirmé par titre
par contre faut savoir qu'en tournée
nous on avait entre 2 et 300 euros il
avait 450 euros par soir te tourner mais
il faut savoir qu'on a dû faire nous par
exemple sur la première on a dû faire à
peu près 150 dates on est peut-être en
moyenne 7000 personnes par soir donc ça
fait 708 et spectateurs à combien la
place en moyenne c'était 25 euros y'a
trop mal fait 21 millions d'euros de
recettes et non moi la bonne
affaire
savoir qu'après voilà on s'engageait là
dedans pour après avoir dû très vite ses
terres mais tout n'est pas faux mais les
3000 euros par semaine quand même et les
millions par prime tout ça c'est bon les
francs peut-être peut-être je fais une
parenthèse si la star ac avait eu lieu à
l'époque des réseaux les candidats
auraient fait une fortune mais pierrick
gigantesque
vous auriez a lancé un ba oui j'imagine
j'imagine oui et au fil du temps les
contrats de production se sont
sophistiquées mais je crois même que les
candidats de la star academy gagner de
l'argent sur les photos vous voyez dans
tous les magazines depuis le début il
avait un deal doit été abandonnée en
fait tous leurs droits cependant je
crois dix ans au début tu te disant que
c'était 20 ans et maintenant ces avis ça
tu fais une émission tu donnes tout fait
c'est quand atou tables décorées au
casting en signe un papier en gros soit
pas trop seront signés non plus
attention je ne n'ai gâte c'est pas
négatif c'est comme ça mais en 10e et
voilà bah si tu joues si tu joue le jeu
baisse c'est ça ou rien donc nous ont
signé comme ça et est donc le chercher
parce que c'était sur les plates-bandes
et c'est l'eau qui touchent le moins
d'argent j'étais sidéré parce qu'elle
est même un million jennifer pour
dénicher une guerre ça c'est une avance
sur salaire bah c'est une avancée les
vendent des albums voilà vingt-cinq
céphalées un coup de boule ou quand tu
rentres on donne un million pour
commencer
vous aider un peu le melon
[Rires]
non mais passée la rigueur mais elle est
obligée de rester avec eux après elle
est obligée de faire ses albums dont on
fait quand même même si c'est une avant
ça reste elle est obligée de rester
avant quand tu viendras ça va être
chanteuse a déchanté
c'est à dire que quand on est chanteur
on peut aller chanter partout sauf que
là elle est obligée de suivre les règles
de way était la règle après l'or vient
de chez universal c'est quand même là
bien sûr on est sûr la meilleure chaîne
elle avait la vraie sorcière le ch mais
le single le plus vendu de la star ac'
un fait l'agitateur
[Applaudissements]